Danny Masterson fired from Netflix the  ranch amid claims of sexual assault  [Music]  on Tuesday the streaming service made  this announcement quote the producers  have written Danny Masterson out of the  ranch Monday was his last day on the  show and production will resume in early  2018 without him Netflix has not yet  decided if Masterson's credit as one of  the executive producers of the ranch  will remain the actor responded to the  news in a statement I am obviously very  disappointed in Netflix's decision to  write my character off of the ranch from  day one I have denied the outrageous  allegations against me I have never been  charged in a crime let alone convicted  of one in March the Los Angeles Police  Department launched an investigation  after three women came forward claiming  Masterson sexually assaulted them in the  early 2000s Masterson denied the  allegations and no charges have been  filed  [Music]